thousands of families have escaped from
the deadly California wildfires are
returning home to find nothing but
rubble one little boy in Santa Rosa lost
his house and his cherished collection
of baseball cards and memorabilia
baseball team from around the country
are coming together to help replace what
he lost Adriana Diaz was there when the
nine year olds favorite team surprised
him and made some of his biggest wishes
come true every day nine year old Lauren
Smith pretends to play for his favorite
team the Oakland A's
while slugging at home plate but his
real home is gone reduced to inches of
ash after wildfires hit Santa Rosa
California I just fought like crazy
Laurens father Tate tried to protect the
house with the hose he's ran around the
house and I just watched everything
burned they lost everything including
Lauren's treasured baseball cards and
other memorabilia and they meant the
world to you yeah the day after the fire
he was you know just so heartbroken and
crying and you know I lost this I lost
that you know my Ricky Henderson
baseball Lorenz on suggested he tell his
favorite team what happened in a letter
to the Oakland A's I love watching you
raise games and I want to be news player
my brother and we have so much fun but
he's only nine months old I'm nine and
I'm teaching him out just throw boss I
had every single card from 2000 to now
and it all burned up so sad the A's
answer in person or now we do it I got
your letter the A's president surprised
Lauren Friday along with the team's
catch her are you excited yeah awesome
here's Bruce Maxwell
they brought Lauren memorabilia from the
A's other teams and from fans who read
the letter do you wear this bag take
that a backpack to school what do you
think of that pretty cool
thank you to bag right since mine
for one day this little leaguer was a
sports star but the team didn't stop
there and we want to make sure that you
get out to the Coliseum this year too so
we got you full season tickets have you
ever thrown out the first pitch and
baseball game you want to do next year
yeah game on
don't play some catch let's do it who
better to practice with than the A's
catcher Bruce Maxwell and this smile
says it all Bruce told us to have a
really good arm I wasn't throwing hard
to him cuz he centers the postseason you
were taking it easy on him yeah what did
you think when you first read his letter
I honestly I read about half of it out
of stop it was emotional yeah a little
bit a little bit definitely to see that
he's still in a positive light within
himself and his family is something
that's inspirational to a lot of people
Warren wanted to share that positivity
and his gifts with his friends they lost
their home stone you gotta get give away
my other friend lost his house entirely
and he had some really valuable stuff
and I just want to give him away because
I have too much and I don't have
anywhere to put it
now he just has one more wish I want
them to make it to the World Series
again well it's it's been a long time
it's been almost 30 years the A's may be
underdogs but Lawrence says they've
taught him how to step up to the plate
we ready no matter what life throws at
you one very three for CBS this morning
Adriana Diaz Santa Rosa California all
right now who says I'm out in the great
country you know what I said the cat
home right Oakland A's